so my talk is about advanced software
testing for data scientist advanced it's
always something subjective so we're
definitely gonna go beyond writing a
simple unit test okay so we're going to
look at beyond that I'll give a quick
overview still and a refresher but we'll
look at what's the journey after that
okay it's a quick raise of hand who who
likes Python in this room wow we're in
the right conference then so that's a
good start this tutorial is actually
suitable for both developers and data
scientists so who considers themselves
more a developer oh cool
sweet what programming language do you
use mostly okay cool awesome and who
consider yourself more of a data
scientist all right amazing well you're
in the right place as well so that's
goodness so my name is Raul only my mom
calls me Riley Brielle
so Ravel is fine and I'm from Cambridge
Park so what we're gonna cover in this
tutorial is a few questions that
hopefully we'll get some answers by the
end of this tutorial so one is is my
code correct and the challenge is
actually more difficult when your data
scientist because you write a lot of
code related to modeling and feature
engineering so how do we know whether
it's doing the right thing
then you know obviously writing test is
gonna be a way to find out if we're
doing the right thing I'm going to
define what being right means but how do
you write do test so there's guidelines
and practices to try test the
maintainable and
most honorable and we're also going to
look at how do we generate our tests so
I'm just gonna quit this calendar so it
doesn't jump up in hell so you know
writing tests might feel like it's
boring it's taking a lot of time so
wouldn't be nice if it was done for us
right so you know we remove nice if code
was written for us but that's another
topic and finally how do we deal with
system dependencies because in the real
life you know you deal with a number of
cloud services a number of rest api and
endpoint different database
and those my all impact the code that
you write so that's also very important
so let's take a look at the outline so
I'm gonna motivate what testing for data
science means the challenges around
testing for data science it turns out I
believe it's a lot more complex than
traditional software development so
that's going to be really fascinating
then we'll review the testing tools
available in Python I might be already
familiar with some of them maybe some
are going to be new we'll talk about
unit testing the principles we'll look
at panel tries test assertions available
when you do a pandas and in PI how do
you write the test then we're gonna go
on an epic journey we're gonna take the
buzzword compliant bandwagon property
based testing so that's gonna make
everyone sound really smart at the fancy
dinner party we all love that so next
time you sit with your managers like hey
property based testing super cool so
comes with a caveat I believe it can be
useful in certain scenarios in some
scenarios actually may be overrated so
that's my take on it so we'll we'll take
a look at what it means and then we'll
talk about test doubles and mocking so
getting rid of system dependencies so
this is my slide where you have the
setup hopefully hopefully hopefully
everybody did it before coming here it
is in the abstract of my tutorial
there's requirements and the repository
so take a photo if you haven't done it
or go to my tutorial description you'll
find it there so what you'll see here is
a git repository with all the code
samples I'm gonna go through and all the
exercises so don't worry if you miss out
on stuff now you'll have it all over
there there is a requirement that takes
theme which you can use to create a
condo environment that's gonna be
oscillator with everything you need okay
so I'm gonna move on in this tutorial
there's a lot of content so I'm gonna
show you a lot of demos there's some
exercises I'll go
Solutions or not but I'm going to move
along fairly quickly okay so it's
important that you stay focus for the
next hour or so okay cool so let me give
you some context so I'm going to assume
that you know you've already developed a
model right you've got some code and now
it's time to figure out how do we test
it all okay so I'm going to use a data
set from kickstart up so let me dive in
straight in the repository so you'll see
a bunch of files and folders in the
project providing that you guys there is
a notebook right here called a tutorial
that I plan B okay so that's what I'm
gonna be loading up now here we go so
there is a data set which is going to be
your train set and again that's
Kickstarter data anyone's familiar of
Kickstarter
do you want to describe what Kickstarter
is amazing exactly and there is
typically a goal that you want to reach
on how much money you collect before the
project goes ahead so here we're gonna
build a model that's gonna predict
whether a campaign will be successful or
not okay
so it's a binary task and there might be
different features of interest here you
know the deadline how many days they are
to collect the money the description of
the text you know that my all influence
whether the campaign will be successful
or not okay so let me show you a little
bit what the data looks like this is
real messy data right as multiple
columns you'll see that we have some
Nan's we love Nan's right there is
nested data right so some columns have
JSON data which had different keys
different values and you know here
consider some nested JSON as well so
we're gonna have to deal with all of
that right so this is a real stuff it's
not an iris dataset okay this is like
how do we write real code for a dataset
eyes may see a nested so that's the
context now I went a step ahead and I've
already implemented a model which is
available in a cycle model that PI and
what I've got going on here is PI charm
it's my preferred ide when i could in
python you can use whatever you fancy so
what you'll see here is the way I
structured the code it makes use of the
pipeline and transformers API in psyche
law so that allows me to modernize my
code have different reusable components
responsible for feature extraction and
transformation if you're not familiar
with the scikit-learn pipeline and
transformer api that's okay don't worry
about it I strongly encourage you to
learn more
and you'll see there's other PI data
tutorial that covers this topic well
since she allows you to write coda is
more maintainable and composable okay so
here I've got a pipeline and I'm setting
up it's going to do some sort of
featuring generating apply one hot
encoding on it so just to give you a
flavor so this category extractor here
is another piece of code I've returned
and what you'll see you know it's gonna
try and figure out what are the
different categories associated to a
crowdfunding campaign okay so we've got
some piece of code here it returns the
pandas dataframe I'm gonna have another
transformer here that as you'll see here
is going to do some sort of currency
conversion so different campaigns might
be raising money you know in different
currencies of Canada Europe US UK so
this is trying to normalize the amount
value to USD okay so those are all
different transformation and stuff that
you'd be doing as a data scientist so
all the code is already written and as
you can see you know there's multiple
lines of code here how do we know
whether it's doing the right thing my
model is making use of all those
different transformers composing them
together etc and then you know training
the model is the simplest task at that
point right logistic regression and
we're happy okay so then the real art is
in the feature engineering space right
and that's where you can use your domain
expertise and figure out what is going
to be relevant and impactful for the
overall performance of the model so how
do we test it all how do we get
confidence that this is doing the right
thing that's the first question that
comes to mind and that's what I'll be
covering in this tutorial and we'll
learn different techniques to work with
that
excellent so testing for data science so
our first question is what is it that we
actually you're testing because there's
so many different things that you know
our worth we're testing so first of all
there is the difference between the
functional requirements and the
non-functional requirements so what I
mean by functional requirement is is my
model at putting a prediction in a range
that we expect you know if it's a yes of
a no is it true or false then it should
be you know just to vent it's nothing
else right so that's a functional
requirement does it do the right thing
is it correct as part of the
specification is the pre-processing in
the passing logic correct so if we've
got some sort of JSON object we're
extracting a field and we're converting
that field to us D is the conversion
formula correct right so this is input
to output so that's what I mean by
functional requirement we've written
some business logic we want to test that
the business logic matches the
specification but that's not the only
thing right actually the space for
non-functional requirements there's a
lot richer so as the decider is
obviously you know we we love working
Jupiter notebook and so on but then it's
like well how do we prediction eyes a
work right so at some point we'll go
from a notebook to a series of files and
classes it gets packaged up and then
deployed perhaps as a rest service right
which you know a different team could
could utilize so I raise this question
on you know is the model able to handle
a different request right so how many
requests per second can it handle do we
have a sort of SLA in terms of the
latency of the prediction you know so
let's say classic example of fraud
detection latency at this point is very
important so you don't want to be
waiting several hours or even several
seconds right you want to have
milliseconds and that's really important
because different models might have a
high complexity might be slower in
comparison to simple models are faster
right so there's all non-functional
requirements now there's also the
question of model performance if we push
an update to a model how do we know
whether there's a performance
improvement in terms of different
metrics that we might be deciding on so
we need to keep track of which training
data set we train the model with which
test dataset we trained on what was the
history and did we actually get an
improvement right so that's also
important now today people also talk
about explain ability of a model
how can you justify a certain decision
is made can you explain in layman terms
to maybe a business person so I consider
that also part of the sort of a
non-functional requirements right you
might have to provide a good
justification that this model is simple
to explain but that's not functional
requirements we don't really have a an
input and output that we can match based
on a specification those are other
requests and I read this paper from
booking.com
which has a really fancy catchy name 150
successful machine learning models six
lessons learnt right and those guys also
talked about non-functional requirements
so they say prediction serving latency
is really important for a model so what
I found out is if they had like a 30%
increase in latency so that means
there's a slow down right now had a
direct impact on a conversion rates for
their booking right survey is like poor
five percent but point five percent when
you you know scale at the massive scale
it's a lot of money right so latency is
a massive concern so as a data scientist
perhaps that's something we need to keep
in mind when we productionize a work and
work together of data engineers and
developers the other one is it's great
to test the performance of your model in
the evaluation step which is correct the
notebook but what happens afterwards
when it's deployed how do we know
whether the model is still behaving as
we expect now that we have inputs that
we
never seen before right so the idea of
actually doing some sort of response
distribution analysis so if we look at
the distributions of the output or
losing line wave what we'd expect the
model to be or not right so the story
continues after do not work and finally
I thought one of the most interesting
point was the model performance is not
the same as business performance right
so what it means is you know pushing to
get 99% accuracy doesn't necessarily
mean that we get business value you're a
useful business outcome out of it it
might be that at some point as some
threshold you plateau in terms of the
business outcome that you can get out of
this piece of work right so those are
all discussions actually happening
beyond is my code correct okay so really
encourage you to read a newspaper now in
my tutorial we're going to focus on
functional requirements okay so we've
written some code we want to get
confidence that the code is matching the
specification okay so it's context super
so why are we testing does this look
familiar to you pretty much a standard
Monday morning in Manhattan you know I
was taking a an uber on Monday morning
instantly regretted it stuck in traffic
so I've experienced the New York subway
for the first time my life this week
that was pretty cool cool so you know
the point here is in ideal scenario you
know we want to have a smooth journey we
want to go to a to be really fast
there's nothing unexpected right that's
kinda like we don't want to be stressed
out this is stressful so how can we
write code that is not like that and
that's the point of a why are we testing
we want to be stress-free when things
are deployed in production okay now
unfortunately the data science workflow
is super complex and I believe more so
than software development
so myself to development let's say we
implement a web application you know
there is a finite set of concerns that
you worried about right you've got some
sort of data storage you've got a
front-end and you might be having some
business logic around it right that
that's the software development space
when it comes to web develop now in data
science there's so many different things
the one is you know the business
requirements you know so you have to
engage your stakeholders and then you
figure out well we're going to need some
data to accomplish the goals and the
requirements so what data is it where is
it stored and what data formats so today
we deal with Jason CSV Park a different
binary formats so we need to learn it
all right and they all have different
trade-offs and all might be useful in
different contexts depending on querying
efficiency depending on the storage size
okay so that's just data formats then
there's so many different database
technologies right so you've got the
sequel space the no sequel space within
sequel you might have like a document or
an to storage you may have graph
databases then you replicate the same
thing if you want to scale in terms of
petabytes or gigabytes and depending on
the latency trade-offs that you want to
have so it's really complex right so
that's just the first part data
collection now you have different
specialists here you've got data
engineers or even database specialist
great now we have some data stored
somewhere with some query language and
so the next step is well we can't really
use this data right it's raw data we
need to press build some sort of data
assets now gonna be utilized by wider
teams in the company so we're to embark
on a whole process of cleaning the data
so I see you smiling over there so
you're probably thinking yeah this is
what's going on in my company right now
great data assets fancy Burswood
great so data cleaning and again there's
different skill set here you know you
might be using a sequel right to get the
data maybe clean it up there you might
then call pandas to the rescue because
the SICU queries become really messy you
don't get it right so let's just pandas
maybe do some imputation clean up the
nons etc then well good we've got some
data assets and so on but I do know
today we want to build a machine
learning model so if you don't have
labels if you don't know what is it you
want to predict or something like that
then it's still gonna be useful so yeah
there's another process unlike can we
label the data and maybe this is where
you bring up stakeholders again and then
might have a fancy UI right kind of
label the data for you and what not cool
then you've got feature engineering
right so yes data scientist cool we've
got some domain expertise let's see what
we can engineer and then training is
only one small aspect of all of this
right so like cool scikit-learn geonets
yolo right cool
get a nice model evaluated then like
well it's not really great at this point
it's go back to feature engineering
iterate when you deploy it
so deployment might be that you package
it up as a library for other people to
use it or maybe that you decides you
have a rest service with an endpoint
that software developers can utilize
right so you've got separation of
concerns amongst different teams and
you've to monitor this whole thing so it
is like really complex now the bad news
is that each of these components
typically is maintained by different
people with different skill sets and the
whole thing is to be tested right so
where do we even start so things are
tough right now I'm gonna make it even
more difficult all of this obviously you
have dependencies you have dependencies
on you know data or work where is it
files but web api's so Web API might be
rate limited so you can't use it anymore
or there might be an incompatibilities
in terms of the results so that nice
JSON object does return the shape might
changed so that's gonna impact your code
as well am i dealing with databases
database can be out of service there
might be a bottleneck you might be
relying on different cloud services AWS
GCP Azure you name it right so on top of
this complex workflow you have external
factors that are out of your control
right but you need to keep that in
consider
when you write the code in when you test
it now again there's a really nice paper
which I was really impressed about
because this is one of the most
prestigious software engineering
conference in the world and they talk
about you know machine learning for
production so this is software engineers
so strongly encourage you to to take a
look at it here's the reference awesome
so what are the challenges
well we deal with many different data
formats from CSV to park' to JSON and so
on we have to work with external
dependencies we have black box models
that you know we don't really understand
how they operate right so like I can
poke the state of the model to
understand if it's doing the right thing
or not it just has some sort of
prediction and the prediction is also
non-deterministic so I might not get an
accurate number I always get this sort
of weird floating-point value that one
day is slightly different the other one
so how am I supposed to have a
predictable test thing that context now
we deal a lot with teams that have
multiple skill set so data scientist
works with a data engineer that works
with developers and a business person so
everyone is have a common for Kamerion
common software development practice so
yeah so that's the story so testing for
data science is a fascinating space I
don't think everyone has figured it out
yet right so what I'm going to to
tourist you describe a few techniques
that are available in the software
development a world that I believe are
useful for machine learning as well so
don't worry this is fine you know I just
wanted to be completely honest with
everybody here about the difficulties
and now let's dive into some solutions
so why are software testing so by self
to test an automated software testing
right you can still test something but
click around and saying the results here
we we want to embark on an automated
process so perhaps are the most boring
one is you know finding bugs right we'd
like to find out something is not
behaving as expected so we can fix it
so users are not going to be pissed off
or the stakeholders are not going to
question things
so that's the first thing right so
that's why we test now I think Wanda is
even more important in the context of
software development collaboration is
removing the fear of changes you know
you implement business logic for feature
extraction and for modeling somebody
else is gonna refactor your code or make
incremental updates how do we know that
this person or other teams have not
introduced new bugs right so having an
automated test suite they can repeatedly
run to catch regressions is the way to
remove that fear right of making changes
now the second third one is enhancing
the debugging process if a test fails
you get a diagnostic on why did it fail
and that will guide you on finding out
the root of the issue and finally it's
really about increasing confidence
before we move to production because
once it's in production things are
always more expensive to fix
then on your local computer right
because at this point it's public other
people use a reputation of damage it's
harder to make change something that is
deployed because you have to interact
with multiple people so that's kind of
the ultimate reason of why your software
testing it is so important so let me
review the different tools available in
in Python and then I'm gonna focus on
one of them called PI test anyone heard
of dog test yeah cool
completely useless all right it's cute
right so it's got its perks so you can
see that we've got our favorite doc
string here so doc string is just a way
to document what a function or method
might be doing inputs and outputs and
then where you see here in bold in my
slide with the 'greater operator is an
invocation of this a function and below
the output so doc test is a tool that
will catch all those special invocation
run the function with
the input and then do a string match
based on the output ok so just a way to
test that your documentation is correct
so make sense now
there's pros and cons the pros are the
learning curve is absolutely minimal
right anybody can say this is the
function this is the output I expect
right the syntax is really familiar now
the downside is there isn't a great use
case in the context of continuous
integration so continuous integration is
the process where you make a change to
your code you push it the server will
run some tests and give you some
feedback ok now in practice when you
write real code you're going to have
pandas dataframes
you're going to have to write assertions
that go beyond a string equality check
right you might deal with different data
structures you might deal with different
properties things are greater and
smaller and so on you'll deal with
databases that you might have to setup
and teardown so there's system
dependencies and so on
so writing real test requires a lot of
things that doc test doesn't provide it
just does a simple string equality check
okay so it's not suitable for the real
world so the only purpose is about
validating documentation now you often
see doc test you know in like libraries
that are really unknown where people
have a dog story and quick examples that
help you about like you know how do I
use this rather than is it doing the
right thing next is unit test so that's
a package part of the standard library
anyone used unit test ok cool cool so
unit test is a package dies typically
adopted and maybe let's see the proof is
in the pudding did you use unit tests
before yeah so in c-sharp I believe
there's like a similar API right cool so
unit test is designed around classes and
methods so it's designed with an
object-oriented programming approach so
that's why it's typically adopted by
software developers because this API has
been
for several years so people already
familiar with the classes and methods as
part of the unit test library so not
just in question right so maybe I should
go back to a dislike this is fine this
is fine stay tuned yeah yeah yeah so
let's go back to writing some tests
maybe so yes yes really popular from a
software development ecosystem because
it takes this class as a method approach
now there's downsides with that so
there's more boilerplate they have to
write you know you have to declare class
it's subclass of test case this message
that you need to write I'll show you
some examples and is limited diagnostic
so there's only a few assertions that
you can use like you know assert equal
or lesser true and it's kind of stuff
you'll see that PI tests and other
session library provide a much richer
vocabulary now marbles is like the new
cool kid on the block it's an extension
for unit tests so it looks at addressing
some of the issues that unit tests
excellent should have written say unit
test in a sandbox environment before
pushing to production great that's the
main takeaway of my tutorial I love it
so models sir mobiles in essentially
enhances unit test with better
Diagnostics provides you with
information around the test failures
what are all the local variables and
what the states are at the point of
failure so that's going to help you in
the debugging process so we're looking
at demo in a moment and then PI test
everyone use PI test before right so
typically PI test is the preferred
testing tool in Python by data scientist
and the reason is as they a scientist
you know typically you might be coming
from a more masse kind of background so
you familiar with functions writing
simple functions with no bullet plate
that's the attraction point there's
enhanced diagnostics in comparison to
unit tests so there's one simple
assertion called assert but it's it's
overloaded in a way that will pick up
different data structure different types
and provide kind of custom diagnostics
around it
it supports a parameterize test so
that's a way to decouple the test itself
from the data that it uses so the inputs
and output so that gives you more
flexibility in terms of reusing the same
a test templates so that is the Korres
more maintainable it has also something
called fixtures so fixtures is actually
power choice test is an example of a
feature but the idea of for example
having a setup and a teardown process
when you're making use of a database or
when you're making use of a system
dependency right so PI test provides all
of that and it's the preferred tool by
data scientist so let's look at let's
compare those three different tools so
we all have kind of a good idea and then
we'll deep dive into PI test and other
techniques so what you'll see in the
folder there is different files
available in the test directory so let's
start with unit test
so here's an example of a test case
written using the unit test standard
library so it's important I've got a
class its subclass a test case a test
case will give me special methods to
write assertions so those would be
inherited so I've got a test here that
given a pandas dataframe and given my
country transformer let's apply this
transformer on the data frame and then I
can write a series of assertions to see
that the result is as expected
okay and I've got another unit test here
so let me see if I can make this one
fail yeah cool oh I'll delete a few
things make some tests fail so we can
see some mess I might put so I'm gonna
run a unit test
it's called test country for formers
that you test whoo boom so this is an
example of an output that you'll see so
this specific test here which is called
test and cone an unknown country where
it says default we see that one of the
assertion failed so immediately you can
see the diagnostic is current imitates i
i'd only have the source code around it
i've got a trace back or where the
failure happened okay so that's unit
test now let's look at running the same
thing using marbles so the benefit of
using marbles is there isn't much that
you need to change you just need to save
marbles and then we can run exactly the
same thing and what you see here we've
got some a bit of an enhanced
diagnostics here so we've got the
different lines of code that's around
the test failure we have all the local
variables and this state that is part of
the diagnostics okay so this is connect
the two data frames that we use the one
is the sample and the other one is the
result okay so that's that's mobiles
subscribe nice little friend to add in
if you're ready using unit test it
retrofits immediately you just change
the module on how to test actually
executed okay cool now let's look at a
PI test so here's an example of the same
sort of a test but written using PI
tests as you can see things are already
more concise you have to worry about
classes and master and so on you just
write the simple functions and the
assertion is basically just one function
called a set which you can utilize to
check whether things are correct or not
so let's run that again in the common
line to see what some output we get so
let's use PI test
boom so what we can see here is that
we've got one failed test one that
passed the failing test it's this one
and this is where things failed you can
see the coda rounded is provided there's
some nice little colors that's cute
so typically what PI tests will do is so
this is simple example but let's say you
had a function call available as part of
the assertion it will tell you this
function call return this result and
that's the thing that failed right so it
can like try and be friendly with the
error message so let's say let's fix
this and see what we get so I had an an
and we expect Adam so what I can quickly
do here is for every non value we'll
replace it with other so that's if the
country is not found in a default list
now I can rerun my test and what we'll
see is we'll get a nice green bar okay
so to test past yeah so that's a demo
for pi test cool so let's deep dive a
little bit into a PI test and other
assertions available thumbs up so far
everybody cool so I think the first
question is how do you structure a
project when you've got source files
like feature extraction and you
transformer your pipelines your model
and also a bunch of tests right so the
good news is the software development
community has been structuring large
projects for a long time and this is the
recommended approach so one is have a
source folder where you have all your
modules that are going to be reusable
and that you implement and a separate
folder where you've got your test
modules so the benefit of this approach
is when it comes down to packaging all
the files related to source available in
one single directory so it makes the
packaging process and deployment really
simple okay and all your tests are
available separately that means that the
archive does publish is lightweight now
another approach that you often see in
Python for simple projects is when the
module
so for example transformer dot pie and
test transformer pie available in the
same directory okay so the downside with
that is that it makes the packaging
process more difficult because you need
to filter out which files we select
which file do we not select and wrap
this stuff up now the upside of that is
when it comes to importing things are
really simple right because the Python
path will load the module that is
available in the same directory so when
test transformers depends on
transformers if it's in the same
directory it's simple it's there right
so it's it's reusable so what I
recommend is split up the source and the
test and when comes to wiring up the
Python path typically that's the script
or configuration that you write that
does it for you okay but the benefit
here is this clear separation of
concerns so there's an exercise to do
we're not going to have time for
everybody to code every exercise say so
what I'm gonna do is to introduce the
exercise show you the solution but when
you go home you can do all the exercises
in your time and I'll publish the
solution after the tutorial ok so let's
take a look together so what you'll see
there's a folder called exercises and in
this first exercise what you need to do
is to write some tests for our
categories extractor so the categories
extractor is something that takes a JSON
string and needs to extract categories
out of these JSON string okay so now
Jason string will be structured like
this so you'll have like a key called
slug and then you'll have a faint I
would say music and then rock okay so
you're gonna have to write a test we're
giving a JSON string the categories
music and rock are actually retired okay
so there's a bit of parsing going on
here and I'll show you later on it turns
out this is actually a much more
sophisticated problem than it looks like
and this is where hypotheses will come
handy okay
so you'll need to use PI test to do that
now let me walk you through solution
rights they might look a little bit like
this so you provide a sample you call
the categories extractor and then you
assert that the output is as you expect
okay so that's gonna be the first
exercise that you do when you go back
home cool so let's keep going
so the next topic I want to talk about
is well Rowell you know in data science
we use this library that developers
don't use you know we use pandas we use
numpy you know okay we write tests when
we have this kind of weird instructions
what I'm glad you asked the question
because the answer is yes so let's look
at a let's look at a demo of where
things might go wrong so let's just look
at this example here
okay so here's an example of a test that
you know set some stuff up a goal adjust
them so the goal i justá-- is a
transformer that will do the currency
conversion to USD okay and take the
pandas dataframe returns another pandas
dataframe will transform it and then we
like to check that the result is as
expected so you might be tempted to
write something like this right is the
result as we expect sounds good
so let's run this into PI test and see
the result we get
whoo I don't know how you guys feel
about this but it doesn't look
particularly inviting and friendly
friendly looks a little scary there's a
lot of value era stuff going on
so the the error is this one so it's
basically say wait a minute you got
pandas dataframe here in the context of
a boolean expression what does it mean
for the planet's data frame do you think
that all the elements are true or is the
pandas different non empty what is it
right so actually it turns out what we
want to do here is to do an exact
equality check for all the elements and
columns inside the pandas dataframe
that's really what we want to assert on
now for this there are special
assertions available that are provided
as part of the pandas library that you
can use if you have to do a quality
check on a data frame and index or a
series so let's let me show you the
difference now so I'm going to use the
third frame equal assertion so that
comes from pandas itself now we can
rerun or test the test passed it's great
now let's make it fail to see if we get
any sort of good diagnostic so let's
make that three here so my test is going
to fail on purpose just so you see the
diagnostic that this assertion will
produce so what you'll see here a bit
more friendly writes on the left side we
had a data frame with the number 30 then
we had 20 on the right hand side so
something has been wrong here so that's
a lot more useful than the ambiguous
value error okay cool so if you're
writing tests and using pandas make sure
that you incorporate the pandas
assertion sweet cool next topic we're
going to talk about a permit rice test
now typically when you write a test
you're gonna check for multiple inputs
and multiple outputs right because
there's different scenarios that may be
interesting testing including edge cases
so typically things like you know a 0 or
negative number
and then expected values are provided by
stakeholders but the template for the
test is always the same
now you can copy/paste your test
multiple times change the inputs and
outputs which is great if you're paid by
the number of lines of code that you
write right see the lady does that yeah
absolutely
unfortunately we don't live in that
reality right great great great good
stuff right here we're gonna learn a new
trick that's gonna help us you know
write tests that are more maintainable
so what I mean by that is decoupling the
logic of the test versus the input and
output that actually feeding to that
test okay so let's look at an example so
this is written using a PI test so what
you see here is an example of a
parameterised test so here we're
specifying a list of inputs and outputs
so dorable is syntax just now can
explain what's going on
so I've got a list and each element in
the list is a tuple the tuple
constitutes of an input and an expected
output okay so in this case the input is
a panel data frame and the output is
another pandas dataframe how many test
cases do I have here three excellent so
what you can see is that we clearly have
a separation of concerns we've got one
part which is like setting up the inputs
and expected values and then the other
part is actually what's the template for
my unit test so the way this works is
using a despise test feature called a
palm tress test and what that's going to
do is to say look we're taking this list
of test cases here this is a description
of the input and output now my test gets
this data injected so that's done by PI
test
and the template itself essentially can
utilize those arguments but what's
important is that for every run PI tests
will plug in each of the test cases
available in that list so let's run that
into the command line just to see what's
going on so how do you call this
transformers parametrized that's a cool
name
boom so what you can see in here
interestingly is that says tree test
passed right as a push to one and that's
because you had three test cases now I
can make you know let's just uh make
this one I fail so we see an example of
what will happen right so in this case
we had two tests that passed and one
that failed because I just simply
changed one of the input to to make it
fail okay so a power choice test is a
good feature because it allows you to
write tests are more maintainable you
focus on the template and when it comes
to providing new inputs and outputs you
have a single place to do it so it makes
it really simple to add new edge cases
and new records
just to make sure I understand the
syntax so basically that don't will can
take any shape so all the different
variables and then on that dream
basically you just are passing like
valuables into your death Creek and the
test now is paralyzed using that input
or not but then that's what gets fed in
every time cool so there is another
exercise which is called test exercise 2
and in this exercise you'll see that we
have a time transformer
a time transformer is one of the feature
extractor in this domain so we deal with
time stamps so there's a deadline for
the crowdfunding campaign that's the
time stamp
there is the creation of the campaign
there's when it's actually launched so
might want to create features like how
many days until the deadline or this
kind of stuff right so that's why the
transformer does and you have to write
some tests to check that the logic is
correct and because there's multiple
time stamp possible you might be
interested in using primary test right
and an edge case would be you know a
time stamp of zero for example what
would it mean so that's the other
exercise and you know like a solution
would would look like that
so you set up your test cases again a
list of tuples and then you provide a
template that calls the time transformer
with a sample data frame and then an
assertion here using the third frame
equals because we deal with pandas
dataframe okay
cool so now that we've learned how to
use a PI test we looked at a assertion
specific for pandas we looked at Pam's
rest test what does it mean to actually
write a good test so that's my next
question so there is a framework that
you can adopt which allows you to simply
structure a unit test it's called a
given wind and pattern so it's not a
design pattern or anything like that
it's just a way for you to write a test
so that when somebody else looks at it
they immediately recognize the three
different parts right so one part is the
preconditions so those are inputs that
you're going to be using as part of your
test the second part is actually the
behavior that we want to test so that's
called when and the final part is the
post conditions what is it we want to
verify so those are the three parts and
you can make those parts
explicit in your code and the way that
looks it to be like that so you make
adequate use of spacing to make it clear
what the different parts are so we have
got my given step so have a goal adjust
the different variables are going to be
using the behavior I'm going to test and
then different assertions okay
so the objective here is to write tests
there are more maintainable and readable
by other people now another way to write
good tests is by trying to bridge the
gap between the the business domain and
the code so that's using a language
that's closer to English so closer to
what business professional would be
using so for example here you see this
code I said being a and seeing a and
learn a cause equals two that might be a
bit of a lien to someone that you know
doesn't have a technical background or a
developer background now the second part
here is written using a library called
PI truth and it's a bit closer to the
domain where I saw that a contains
exactly B and C so writing decorative
test essentially having a richer
vocabulary to specify assertions now
closer to the two English so PI truth is
an assertion a live
maintained by Google his different
examples she might want to say that you
know astraying starts with a prefix it
has a given length so there's a nice
method call has length something is
nonzero it contains all n right so this
is the vocabulary that you can use so
let's look into the little demo of how
that looks like so I'm jumping back to
the notebook which is available in the
notebooks folder so PI troof so allah
import the asset that function then i'm
going to look at one of the lines in my
data set right so this is one of the row
so you see we've got different columns
each column has different values and I'm
going to specify some assertions on that
so the first thing I may wish to say is
well it's the deadline nonzero what do
we think the answer is so I've got
deadlines here and it's nonzero so I
execute this line here my notebook you
see nothing happens because there wasn't
any assertion failure now I could check
to see if it's 0 so I'll just write is 0
and if I run that what you'll see is
that we have an assertion error and
there's a nice diagnostic that is
generated so it's not true that the
value is 0 okay so the benefit of using
a richer camera for assertion is that
you also get enhanced Diagnostics now my
wish to write another session here so I
said that the blob contains NYC so let's
check so the blur here
we'll see if NYC's contains so I run
this with an assertion error and what
does that say so it says that original
songs so this is the text should have
contained NYC but it's not the case
ok now maybe I can write songs
if I rerun that nothing's gone wrong so
that's good okay call so the benefit of
you know decorative test is if you work
quite closely with you know the business
team or different stakeholders you can
really get them involved in the process
of writing the test review then this is
where the sort of library comes a handy
on top of providing better Diagnostics
then something like a cert so how do you
write good test
well test should be treated like normal
code right the other day you write code
whether it's code dies for a model
featuring is just code so let's adopt
the same a good principles so here's an
example of a bad test what is bad about
it I see the gentleman smiling at me
saying pretty sure rohui's copy pasted
that from a code base is that what
happened here you love magic numbers yes
so what does the five mean what's one
zero one what's ten no idea no actually
generally don't know anything else yeah
what is that we testing with test one
huh test 1 so this is so important
especially in the context of continuous
integration right so git push go see a
server you get a log with problems if
these log tells you test one where do I
start
right so that's not going to be helpful
anything else
yep
yeah yeah X yeah what does X mean maybe
we're muddling x-men or something I
don't know you're right so X not really
useful variable naming so the reason so
useful is I don't have any domain
business domain context
I have no idea what we're dealing with
right so I have to think now so we don't
want to be thinking too much hey we want
to know what's going on yeah
and yes very subtle one very good so hey
we're using the unit test library so
maybe shoot spy test right but as the
true is only going to tell you true or
false so I get a log and it's gonna says
true or false it's not gonna be handy
right so here the problem is we have a
boolean expression that's passed as an
argument to this assertion a better
assertion would be a so equal because
Astrid echo will tell you the right-hand
side and the left-hand side and I might
give you an indication what the problem
might be you know like an off by one
error or something like that right here
we're not gonna get any indication
there's one last thing so much bad stuff
for just a couple of lines of code right
no interesting um I haven't seen so much
doctoring written for unit test so
typically you have recognized readable
name for your test and still in self
test one you know test prediction or the
standard output is correct you know
something like nice and for both so when
you have a failure the name of the test
is available in your log right so the
last one is you see this X dot R so what
we've done here is to couple the test to
an internal implementation detail right
so R is a field so if that field has to
be renamed or that field doesn't exist
anymore or it's gonna be a different
data type then your test is gonna have
to be changing as well so typically you
want to test the interface level to
decouple your test from internal
implementation so that's the more subtle
one so that's also bad
so here's an example of a better test so
we're not saving the characters that we
write - anything like that you know it's
nice and bows would clearly indicate
what's going on
they sell magic numbers you know we've
got a variable that provides them in
context or we utilized named arguments
which is a Python a feature for example
hey my constructor I'm plugging into
actually reading with some weights and
then a better assertion mechanism okay
so it's kind of recipe and we also
follow the given wind and pattern
awesome
so to summarize the testing best
practices so verbose naming is better
because you get a log you want to know
what the issue is you want to test
behavior not implementation because if
you test implementation you cop or
yourself to an implementation I might
change the magic number and pattern
don't repeat yourself so more copy
pasting means more maintenance depth so
you might want to look into parameters
test to avoid this and finally you know
assertions are your friend right the
more assertions the more directive they
are then the better Diagnostics
ultimately you're going to get when
things go wrong okay cool so something
that goes hands in hands with testing is
test coverage so test coverage is
essentially a technique that will tell
you which line of code were not executed
when the tests were run that's the only
thing it does now this is helpful to
detect errors in your code which perhaps
you should pay attention to right so if
the test is never executed in lines of
code then how do you know if those lines
of code are doing the right thing so
that's the intuition so coverage allows
you to detect those places and then you
can decide whether you should actually
write more tests to make sure you cover
those paths that you haven't thought
about now this comes with a caveat
aiming for 100% coverage doesn't mean
that your code is correct
it just means that the lines of code
were executed as part of the test suite
but if you have different edge cases
then that might not be unravel
in the coverage okay so that comes with
this caveat so I'm going to show you
them of the output that you can expect
so there's a tool called PI test curve
essentially goes hands in hands with PI
test which you can run so in the folder
in the project I've given you you'll see
there's a script called run dot pi so
let me run a rendered pipe so rendered
PI is a script I've written to make
things a little bit easier for you guys
so allows you to download the data set
train the model test it run all the unit
tests run the coverage so I'm just gonna
run the coverage here when you run it
what you'll see so one of my unit test
is failing so I think that's one of the
things from before but what you're
seeing is output is between those lines
so 54 205 you know I don't have any test
so actually we're doing quite poorly in
this scenario right so this is on the
output and the missing lines this is
where you want to make sure you look
into and write some unit tests to cover
those paths that are not picked up by
the coverage okay
now test coverage is typically part of
your continuous integration process you
know you get push and then before he
goes to deployment so continuous
deployment is they do that when all the
tests pass and Erin's happy push to
production you might want to have a
trash all the hair in terms of how much
coverage you've got before it's
automatically deployed also that's
typically what happens in a real
scenario
cool so there's a third exercise the
four exercises in total so the third
exercise what you'll see is I've got a
test that looks like that and you need
to refactor this test to make use of the
given wind and pattern and perhaps you
use better assertions okay so let's look
at how solution might look like so you
see things are more spaced out and
documented so it's clear what the
different steps are in my test awesome
so I'm doing okay on time actually so
that's pretty good we can move on to the
the buzzword stuff yeah
our
see
yes so let me rephrase the question so
in one of the examples basically my test
was depending on a field right and was
checking the state of that field okay
cool
so that's what I mean by uncouple to an
implementation details because now I'm
checking that my test is what checking
that the fill has the right result right
so where to decouple yourself is to
dependence on on a method which is part
of the API of your class and this method
might be actually calling the field
that's okay but the test never sees that
and the flexibility you get here is if I
had to make change to my class rename
the field or go from a list to a set the
test never sees it right but it's the
responsible to the method to change but
this is only one place I need to change
rather than two
okay cool great so let's take a look at
a property based testing how do you feel
about it you should feel good about it
excellent so let's provide a bit of
background between the two classes of
testing methodologies so one is manual
tests the other one is generative tests
so the idea that Tesla generated for you
now like everything there's pros and
cons I'm not here to advocate follow one
path I'm here to provide you with the
pros and cons and you make your own
decisions on which one you want to adopt
but actually I did find some bugs in my
code using genitive test so we'll look
into this so manual test many pros it's
simple it's easy to write so the
conceptual understanding here is quite
simple even like a business person can
look at your test meal okay yeah I agree
it's deterministic it's going to test
the same thing every time because this
one specific input that you're testing
for and one specific output and they are
fast and speed actually is really
important right in a real project you'll
have hundreds and hundreds of tests you
get push you don't want to be sitting
around for several minutes to get some
diagnostic you
- now can I fix it what's wrong right
you've got some momentum some pace you
want to keep going so that's what manual
tests are so good and popular now
there's a big down sight so the being of
nitro saying you know idea of the day
the whole reason what we're barking on a
testing journey is to build confidence
that things are functionally correct
before we push to production now if I
write a test that checks an input of 2
and the integer space is almost infinite
way so it's not infinite it's at 32 bits
or 64 bits right but one is checking one
tiny little point into a much bigger
search space alright so actually
although you building confidence we're
now actually checking for everything
that's just the reality right of manual
tests now a generative test has a big
Pro is that because we're generating
multiple tests in a certain space which
actually checking more facts so that's
just the basic intuition the more things
we check then the more confidence we get
but as many cons so one is a lot harder
to write meaningful generative tests in
comparison to a manual test and I'll
show you some recipes and examples you
can follow - it's non-deterministic we
are generating inputs on the fly so from
one room to the other one you may have
different inputs that are generated so
it makes things less predictable and
three it's much slower and that's a
normal intuition right because you're
generating more things as opposed to one
case so that's the the landscape now I'm
going to dive into a generative test
now within generative test there is
another class called property based
testing and the intuition here is that
instead of providing a specific input
with a specific output that we want to
match we provide a strategy for
generating inputs together with a rule
that we can check against
so a rule is different from an assertion
that says this is the exact output that
we want to check for hey we have to do
things like is this pandas dataframe
containing two columns is the shape of
the input data frame the same as the
output data frame right so this is
properties that we have to come up with
which are not related to it an exact
contact so that's like the big
difference and once you've got a
strategy to general inputs and those
rules then that's how you generate test
essentially because for every new input
that's generated we'll check that the
rule matches okay here's an example of a
property-based tests using hypothesis so
hypothesis is a tool in Python to write
property based tests so don't worry too
much old syntax I'll jump to a notebook
in a second but what you will see in
bold is a strategy so the notation that
decorates our given comes from
hypothesis so what I'm saying is I want
to generate pandas dataframes hypothesis
reports data frames in Paris oh that's
that's good and they're going to have
exactly two columns one is going to be
called go and the types of the value are
floats the other one is going to be a
static USD rate so that's the name of
the second column and that's also gonna
be floats so that's the strategy and our
hypothesis can go ahead and generate
data frames with exactly two columns
with exactly two names but complete
different float values okay now when I
write my test you know further given
when then pattern right so given a goal
adjuster then I'm gonna apply a
transformation with sample data frame
the sample data frame is generated by
hypothesis using this recipe then we
need to specify a rule now this is where
things get out more complex because I
don't know the output right I don't know
the result so in this case one of the
things I can do is to check that the
shape of the inputs and the output are
the same because that's our own
in math and in logic typically they call
this an invariant right that's something
that always holds true so my environment
gonna be the same now I'll show you some
more useful invariants in just a minute
but I just want you to start
understanding that actually it requires
a different mindset right suddenly
you're not looking at inputs an exact
output you kinda have to think about
properties that always hold true in your
code so this part is called a strategy
and the good news is hypothesis as a
really rich vocabulary specify
strategies so you can generate JSON
objects for example with different keys
and values and attributes they can be
all nested you can use different
character sets okay we're gonna have
things that follow a specific regular
expression right so that's all good
stuff to create inputs that are matching
the real world and then you have to come
up with properties so the art in
property based testing is the property
right so what what are good examples of
properties so let me first show you how
to generate strategies then I'll show
you an example of writing hypotheses and
then we'll talk about different patterns
to write properties so let's go in the
notebook again so I've got a hypothesis
loaded in my notebook and what I want to
show you here is what happens if I pick
different strategies and compose them
together so first of all I'm going to
import strategies to generate text and
list in Python so here's an example of
what happens so I want a list of text so
this is two different strategies that
I've composed together in hypotheses and
what you'll see is that hypotheses
generate you know things like you might
think about like an empty list that's an
edge case and a list with a single
element less with different Unicode
characters because
often makes things fail right so those
are things that we don't really think
about you know when we have a clean
dataset typically things are looking
good for us right but as soon as you
model is served by a service you don't
get some weird requests coming in so
hypotheses potentially is a good way to
test for that now let's say I want to
generate pandas dataframe so there's a
panda's module I'm going to specify a
strategy here that says I want a data
frame with two columns the goal the
static is the rate and above floats so
if I run this what you'll see is a data
frame it's got two columns different
rows with different values right if I
rerun this again you know I've got the
empty data frame you know in different
lengths and different sites right even
some missing values to you right because
that's okay that's kind of what happens
as well in pandas and when you load data
cool now let me show you one that's
going to be useful for my demo and for
one of the exercise so if you remember
in the kick starter data set there's
JSON data and that's a pain right how do
I write JSON data for my test so now I'm
going to look at how to generate that on
the fly so I'm going to load a
dictionary strategy and hypotheses so
that helps me create dictionaries in
Python so dictionary you know key M
values and some text what this line is
doing here is to say generate a
dictionary that has exactly one key
called slug and the valley is a text
okay and then let's generate some
examples any see some examples are
generated so you can see the same key
for the dictionary occurs because that
slug have specified that and then the
values are different strings they're all
looking interesting in weird whites or
empty straying just double quotes of
special characters and so on now if you
want strings to follow a specific recipe
a specific character set or a specific
format you can do that too
there's a from reject strategy that
generates text based on a regular
expression so for example here let me
just load that you can see ah and etc
right so that's another way to to create
text now we can all bring it together so
what I'm going to do now is to compose
the dictionary strategy the regular
expression strategy and convert all of
that to Jason so every strategy in
hypothesis supports the map method ok
which is be like the apply method in
pandas right so you specify a
transformation from an input to an
output so what I can do here is to say I
want a dictionary that has one key
called data the value is generated from
a regex then the whole thing I want to
convert that to Jason so I'm going to
map and provide JSON dumps so Jason um
dumps is a function available in Python
that will do the conversion to Jason and
then generate the example and what
you'll see is that we get a string which
is a JSON string that follows this exact
recipe okay so pretty powerful stuff so
now we have a rich way to create inputs
that follow strategies that's part one
part two is let's look into the
properties so let me jump to the demo so
I'm gonna show you an example of running
hypotheses and then together we'll
detect a bug in my code using hypotheses
which I'd never thought about before so
that is good example of way actually
avoid useful so I've got my strategy
here so we'll general pandas dataframe
and I've got a simple assertion here
that's gonna check the the shape of the
input and output I'm just gonna write
another property here which is
essentially going to check that the
adjusted go dice generated is always
greater than zero because we're dealing
with money hand and funding it doesn't
make sense to raise negative money okay
so somewhere my feature extraction and
they need to normalize that the resource
should be always greater than zero and
I'm gonna check if my could pick that
stuff up okay so that's not the bug in
my code but it's like an example of
something to think about
so let's run I put disease so hopefully
that's gonna do it
excellent
cool so this is the output that you'll
see from hypotheses and we'll see
there's an assertion error and it failed
for this scenario here this is the
falsifying example so the goal
hypothesis generated 1.0 for static USD
rate it generated a negative number
that's fine because my strategy was a
float floating numbers this is the sort
of request that I might get over HTTP by
a user and the result was negative
because obviously one x minus y scummy
minus one right so this is an example of
a fail property so my transformer
perhaps here there's different options
available right I know you decide
actually from an input point of view we
should have had a check already at that
stage so maybe a value error should be
thrown at the input level or at the
output level we should normalize that if
there is a negative output it should be
perhaps translated to zero by this
multiple approaches to to fixing this
code but that's something that I didn't
think about when I write I was writing
this code so let's talk about some
properties and then I'll yeah go through
for example is that a configuration that
you excellent question so yeah you can
configure hypothesis or how many
examples to generate by default having
had a hundred generated so you can
decide how many iteration he goes over
and that has a direct impact on the
speed essentially of of running this
process and the good news also if there
is a failure for the next run hypothesis
picks up that falsify example as the
first thing before it ruins the whole
generation again so strategies for
generating inputs as you can see it as
multiple things available for
collections values texts and so on you
can also build your own strategies so
there's an interface that you can
implement it might be a stateful
strategy that on the Flies generates
value for you so it's already flexible
so let's jump into rules so how do we
write rules that actually useful that's
where the art comes in now there are
four classes of rules that you can
specify so one is invariants so that's
something that always holds true so like
the shape of the data frame the size of
the collection are all the values above
a threshold so like they're all positive
it's a lot of things that you can
specify that's not too difficult right
those are things that you can think
about now there is another one that I
personally found not so useful it's
called the run trip so I think that's a
bit more convoluted from the
mathematical form of verification side
right so it's like certain functions
live together so like encode and decode
you expect the same result right so if i
encode something to Jason and then I
immediately decode it I get the same
result right so I could write a property
that says when you code in decode you
expect the same thing so that becomes
like your axiom now in in real code that
you write a scientist I'm like well you
know the the the scenario is where
you're doing a so V encoding and
decoding and you write bespoke code to
do this it's kind of limited so probably
not as useful and not example is reverse
if you reverse something twice you get
the same input
right now III didn't find that many kind
of real situations for that however
things that are all handy is that does
not crash rule so just simply saying
this code here should never throw any
exception in any circumstances right so
here's an example there's conceptually
simple max max of an empty list what's
that supposed to do right like what does
it mean to have maximum I'm sorry so
you'll get a value error right so
testing for the empty list scenario
that's something that you might not
think about right so that's where the
decimal crash rule comes in now the most
useful one which as a data scientist is
called the Oracle test it comes with a
big assumption the assumption is you
have an implementation for an algorithm
feature extraction or pausing which you
know is 100 percent correct that's the
assumption right so that's why it's
called an Oracle it's always right now
typically it's common to have an
interface with multiple implementation
right so you could write a
property-based
test that checks a new implementation
and the output with the Oracle test
right
so that becomes your property right so
the output of this new implementation is
identical at this magic Oracle now if
you have this Oracle then again you get
a benefit of you know test case
generations and then you might find
failure so you know like an exact
sorting or pausing there's so many ways
on how you can sort in pass right like
in Jason you have multiple
implementation of decoding something
from Jason they all have different
speeds and memory trade-off so that
might act as an Oracle okay so let's
dive into a real situation which I did
not think about so it's actually another
exercise which we'll do together so
these exercise yeah extract categories
cool so extract categories if you
remember was this function
that given some inputs that looks like
that music and rock that needs to return
music and then rock ok simple exercise
so what I did was to write a test with a
strategy that generates ooh and to make
it a bit more complicated this is not
just a dictionary it's actually adjacent
string ok so I wrote a test that
generates JSON data and it's gonna check
an invariant so how do we go about this
and then is there certain situation that
I didn't capture so I've written this
solution here for this
this exercise but hopefully you know
I'll walk through and everyone will
understand it so there's a strategy that
creates a dictionary this dictionary has
one key called slug and it's generated
from a regular expression ok so
something that has a slash that
separates out the two categories and
once we've got this dictionary then we
can get a JSON string out of it so far
so good
cool so what's the environment in virus
I'm expecting a list with the two
categories generated so I'm checking for
the shape so that's my invites so let's
let's run this into hypotheses so I'm
gonna run it through the exercises tada
cool we've got a feeling scenario what
is the feeling sinner so the assertion
failed because hypotheses generated
something that somehow has the length of
3 when we expect to so what is that
sinner here's the falsifying example
you sit the double slash so if you have
an input with a double slash and you
split over there / you'll get a list
with three elements they're all empty
strings there's no way I could have
thought about that right like I'm only
human right and you know in the
situation where my service you know is
offered to many users
yeah I'm sure somebody will feed some
input with a double slash right and
perhaps down the line that makes my
whole code crash so that's the issue
so not a founder as I work okay I can go
back and improve the implementation of
my code to handle this scenario and
turns out there is an overload of split
that takes an argument called a max
split which says you split at the first
occurrence of this character and then
that's it so not I do that I can go back
and rerun the test and know it's passed
with hundred inputs that were generated
by hypothesis okay yep five minutes Oh
perfect
final time anyway so hopefully you find
out interesting so and you know talking
to other people that end up using
hypothesis after might role they
actually found some bugs in real code as
well so it is a useful tool right but it
comes this caveat that conceptually you
need to think a little bit differently
and you know it's about environments and
your local test now related topic is
static type checking so python has a
type checker called my pi which you can
look into where you annotate the types
of variables and arguments whether
they're integers strings and data frames
and so on and then you'll get errors
before you run your code so that's also
a property but it's not really around
the the environment itself it's around
the type okay so that's a nice tool to
look into and it's experimental support
for an empire that is being added into
my PI as well so potentially you know
you'll be able to say the specific numpy
array has only integers for example okay
cool
so final topic which I'll I'll go over
marks every detail so who knows who this
person is huh that's true I was gonna
say star-lord but uh okay
that's another way to think about it so
you know when you're about to do
something really really dangerous you
call a stunt man like a double the movie
industry follows is tactic now in code
we also deal with things that are really
dangerous where things can go wrong
those are called system dependencies
right like databases or web api is and
cloud services so the problem is if your
code depends on such a dependency how do
you test it so here is the process data
function and internally it's gonna call
a cloud service or a database so you
have a dependency on that service now if
the service goes down if it's
incompatible then your test is gonna
fail right so how do you get
predictability that your code is doing
the right thing when you have a system
dependency so that's the problem right
so the dependency might not be available
at the time of testing or it might be
really slow so you have to get your
coffee and come back you know something
like that right xkcd style and my return
and predictable values that you had
don't have control of and if the tests
fail it's hard at that point you know if
it's the dependencies problem it's
actually the test itself that is wrong
so we don't know so the solution is
called a test double and it's the ID
that you replace that dependency with
something that has the same interface
but which you can control so it never
actually calls a real thing it's
providing can result that you are
feeding into it so to which say you know
this dependency here whenever it's
called do actually call it we call it
special double well so that's the
concept of mocking and test double those
two things are typically used to mean
the same thing so there's multiple
libraries that provides test doubles so
for example motto provides a testing
library for Bato so butoh allows you to
call AWS services like surprise it same
interface
but there's actually called the surfaces
for testing same fee for flasks and for
Postgres sequel so hey how it looks like
so let's say I've got a preprocessor the
preprocessor called a Dao so domain
access object so they essentially call
the database and returns an object that
matches your domain so something like a
customer right so what we're saying here
is we place that dependency with a
special mark
whenever the load data function is
called this is the value I want you to
return okay so every time that's called
here's a default value so we no longer
have to make a real call to that system
dependency so that gives you control and
now your tests can focus on the main
business logic rather than this
dependency now as a result where you
might have to write as assertions that
check that certain behaviors are
triggered right so in this case I still
want to make sure that it's load data
function is actually called right that
the code will actually trick it there
well I don't actually care about this
function itself where it's been replaced
so there's lots of assertions available
to verify interaction and behaviors
here's a sample of them I invite you to
go through the magic mark documentation
to look at into more detail so I think
I'm gonna conclude here so hopefully you
learned some useful things today and you
feeling pumped up about testing so my
name is Raul again so Jamie spark we did
a science training and recruitment check
out educator AI it's a cool platform
we've built that analyzes code written
by data scientist in order to give them
feedback on the code cool
[Applause]